no
[Music] well
welcome everyone thank you very much
for being here with us today in your
afternoon
we are going to talk today about
programming with r
the first thing I want to mention is
that all these materials and also the
recording of this webinar are going to be
available on our website
at the end of the presentation I am going to
show you where you can go to get
it once the video is available and
also everything that we are going to use today
like the presentation that I have here on
the screen and also all the
materials like  the code and the
information that we are going to use
I also want to tell you that here you
can see my screen there is a way
that you can ask
me questions after I make the
presentation and if we have time I will
try to answer so where it says
questions  in the
bottom part of the
core interface look there you can put a question
and I will try to answer it after
the presentation  n
again very very grateful on
my own part and also on the part of the
studio that you are here in your
afternoon
and we are going to start with the presentation and
the first thing I want to do is
talk about teide bears the first session we
had of  webinar and we introduced the tie
the birds and we talked more deeply
which means what it does and we made
some examples and what I want to do
is that while you watch the other
two webinars that we have done
that he did not study in Spanish what is that you
see  that we are little by little adding
the information
and also learning in a way
that if you watch the three
videos one after the other there is a story
something that you can see from
the beginning to the end
and hopefully this will help you  get more
knowledge on how to do certain things
with r
so the caidí bears talking about it
the diverse street really is a
collection of r packages nr has like
13k packages now and  the tie diverse
is a relatively small group of
those 13 thousand packages that are designed
to work together who is
one of the most famous of the tie diverses
the player I make also small
that they are designed so that you
can and add data the visualization very
easily
the goal of teide vers is to be able to
solve problems that are complicated
by combining different
pieces so if you imagine
yourself a lego when you want to
make a lego house or something like that you are not going to
use the same piece  to be able to put together
something complicated like a house but to
use different pieces to be able to
put together something so big we can see
that there are
these three cultures that professional people make
with these lakes that are
very impressive that is to say one is
bigger than a person  and it
takes a long time to be but thanks to
all these pieces that fit and that they are
exactly
designed so that you can touch to see
with each other you can do this
and that's how bears workshop works
we want all the pieces to
fit together so that you can solve
complicated problems through
data analysis
so last time we talked
about data science and each of the
data science steps and like each of these
steps there are one or several r packages,
especially the devers tag, that help
to do this task more easily,
for example, if you want to read data,
it cannot be easily with a package like
richard for harvest, like this  I want to order you
can skip community transformations
and players visualizations projects and
so you can do all these steps very
easily
up to the point of how to get to
communicate if you want to do a
data analysis to all these packages they
work very well but there are times when
the task that  we have to do it in one or
several steps it is a little more
complicated visually this complication
is very common when it happens when  do you
need to do a type of repeat
or we can call it a loop or an
iteration here like the examples we
have is if you need to read
multiple files into a single table which
is a very common thing that happens when
we're working with data in r here
we have several files, they
all represent a segment or a
part or an amount of time
of the data that we have to analyze
and we have to put them all together and
then analyze them in a single file there
are also occasions where we have to
transform groups of data so we
have them all  this data available in
a table and now we want to run
let's say a model for each group if
we have a table that has many
countries we want to run a model for
each country we have to do these
transformations first then and
then do this type of integration
or cycles or  also if we want to
communicate on the other side
if we want to create multiple reports that
are divided
depending  do a certain segment let's say as
the example that we are going to advise by
students or by countries or whatever
one has to know how to do this
too and not only do it in rp in a
way that is efficient that does not
involve that we have to do
each  report manually
and that is what we want to do today what
techniques can we use to be able to and
to be able to complete these tasks
without much effort and also by means
of a way that is very good or
that fits very well with the tahiti course
the first thing is  talk about
vector functions vector functions that
go beyond teide doors
there are many functions that have this
type of support and that we can
use outside of tight wars
but within freedom well
there are functions that work like this and they are
the first that  we have to
see to do this type of repetitions
for example if we want to do one
we have to extract the name of a
file from several vari  The files that
we have in a variable there is a
function called touchdown and after that
you can pass multiple values and this
unction will automatically repea
the same operation on ea
h of these values and give you th
final file so I don't have
to worry about making a port
loop or a good place to be able to get the
name of each of the files this
can automatically do it last
I'm going to change here to
the code
to show you
how this works so I'm going to load
the try library from  words and now we are going to
load the fs library if I did not use ss
I highly recommend this package because it
helps a lot with respect to
file management so that is how fs
loaded look at them to give me the list of
files inside me inside a folder
in this case I am  working like
this I run this here it will give me all the
files it has
that start with the data name
and as you can see here it gives me three
files  ivos
so now that I have this data and
I can load it into a variable it
can be you can use this
variable to pass to a vector function
so instead of doing this here if
I want the next step it has
marked info
that if I want to see the  information on
the third degree of vertigo that has
third degree I
use fado info and then fourth degree
then fifth degree obviously this
is not practical because if I already have more
degrees I would have to add another line and
all the information that comes
in one for each  result what I
want is for all these results to
be in a single table and that is where
we are talking about how easily I
can pass
info files
and when I do this it
already gives me a single table with the
information of the three files and this
it is thanks to that anger info
if I go to the help information
you hence the tav that is the one I am
passing right now says that it is a vector
up to numeric of 1 multiple  iple files
so when you see this name
here doctor wang normal one or more that's
a pretty good indication that this is
a vector function so I didn't
have to write one in a ford loop
to get the information from  each
one but simply pass
the variable or as I had it
originally I can say directly
here inside and say
data
and it already gives me the information
there are also other packages within the
workshop this is done as brand new
so we have files that have
the  three files and what I want is to
remove the part that says data from each
one, so instead of doing it one by
one, I simply gave it the name of the
files and it makes me automatically repeat
the French for all three, that
this is part of
the  merz hentai that I can easily
make a country
and pass it at this rate which is the one that
removes data and I also want it to
renew csd grade
I make them all 23
and now it automatically takes care of the
res  I have found that I only want to see what
degree each file has and the files are
the ones that are here
so it is very good when one is going to
do this type of programming that I
try
to use these vector functions
the following
and I want to demonstrate
is
when we have to  to do multiple
cycles and in this case we are going to talk about the
package but
this happens for what is it that we are
announcing in the announcement of
this webinar and the reason we do it
is because they really already when there
are no vector functions that we can
to use what is the most efficient way
that we can do to be able to
do this type of cycles or repetitions
as a problem that we want to solve
is the one that we talked about earlier
is to read each of the decades the
three files and then have them all
in one  single table
as you remember we have the 33 degrees
all three in a vat cc file and
what we want to do is read the three and
then  you can use them in r but what
we don't want to do is write
richie stevie three times or put it in a loop
right what we want to do is what is
the easiest way
and that's where it comes from and by how by
easily you can use a function
that is  it calls map and the map function is
expecting two things it expects you to
pass it a group or a list that something
you
want it to want to repeat and
the second thing it expects is the function
or what operation you want
it to pass on that  group or soloist right
now what you are ripping from him
as you can see here we are sending him
three files and we want him to run the
rip function if he is gay
and this what we can see here let's go I'm going
to change again to the code
I want before continuing with him  code
I want to make sure that you can see
the studio
let me ask my partner here
robert gates and older stadiums screen
extremely
well
perfectly good let's see then here
so you can see  I just switched
back to the studio and you can see that I have
exactly the function that I have
checked here
so we are going to read files that
have all three files and after
clicking 7
and if I do this
notice that it automatically
reads all three files
and I  return to a list object
obviously we're not going to see the
list object because we didn't load it into a
variable but if we do this
and go slow
to my environment you can see a list
of 3
and that's the beauty of mac because if
you've used  ere for some time
you know about the beach or the beach this
beach and the question is why don't
we better use this function on a base basis and
you can only use it the only thing that
happens is confusion that beach sometimes
it is not predictable what kind of the
result if you are going to have it may be
that the result is a vector west of
a list or it is a pragmatist with map the
result is always going to be a list
because when you already have something like that so
predictable and easy to use
it is better this type of change makes it
easier especially for a person who
uses this type of functions to
do analysis
so if you use playboy
consider using it more in the future another
advantage that you would have from using it
wrong is that it is not alone it has  an
amat family has other functions that start
with bar
and if we think about it, what marques means to
map is essentially what
is making beer here to the previous one
is that it is like making a map
let's say that you want to be a
scenario person and you want  make sure you
talk to your neighbors so you have
the list of neighbors and the announcement you
want to make so he's doing
a mapping right and all he's
doing here in the next one I'm
showing is that he's the same
operation but  what we want to do
is that the result is a little
different from places is a list the
mapping returns a vector to sanz doctor or
a numeric vector  rich or that returns a
table a vector
that is interior or integer numeric or
true or false then it gives us several
options so that we can
have the values that we need exact
y initi
lly it is in this one that I have here I had
basic and advanced but reall
in a  true we are going to see a
function called transports
today and we are also going to be a function of the
bolt map and so my advice
would be to start with this list
here to practice these functions and
then you can practice these are no
more  difficult they just aren't
I would say as popular as something like
this it's from here so this helps you little by
little to be able to make this change to
use this type of operations
so since we have these examples going
back here to the example that I
was showing you once  that they already have
all the files mapped the next
step I do here is to put them all
together in a single table bain rose is a
command that comes from  The player package
that took a bunch of tables and
put them all together
if I run these two one after the
other
the result is no longer three tables but
it is one table
and it already has all the information I
want because instead of  worry
about uploading each file personally and
then passing it through another program so
that it gives me a table already with two lines
I can already do this but even better instead
of doing this maybe we use one of
the marc family like this one from fr
that returns to  a table that is assembled by
line
which is going to be the same then as 20
but without me having to call it
so instead of being map iván rose I only do
more of that ere media farc it already gives me a
complete table
so here we already have the  table that
we would like to use but there is a
problem if you notice there is not a
grade we don't know what grade each
student is in we just know their
[Music]
results and their enrollment and their other
information but we don't we don't know in  what
degree it is and how it is quite common with
respect to this type of data is that
usually the encoding of such
information is not in the table
but not visually it is in the name of the
file and I because I think that we are
like 70 right now  In this webinar, if
we ask the question of the 70s, which
almost
all of us are going to say, we don't know,
this has happened to us, and if it hasn't happened to you, it
will happen to you very soon,
so if you wanted to do this
demonstration with this type of
problem then there is data inside
the name of the file that we want to
extract the good thing is that all these
pieces these Legos that we use of
such diverse work also that we can
solve this problem very easily
so the first thing that we are going to do
is that we are going
to use  the country if you are not
here the country we can do it
and direct it to the sea land and it gives me
exactly the same result the anses
since this is not a problem I want to
start with e  This is so you can see the
difference the different ways that
one can do another thing I want to
say quickly is that the
efe s the package f s returns me the three
files that start with data but it
also does another very important thing if
you have used the function  names
note that he has names each of
these has a name and automatically
what happens is that fs assigns the
name to each of the files and the
name of that file is the same
name as the file and that means
that  the name or id of
each of these and it's already
automatically prepared for us
because this is important because thanks
to me using efe s/
a instead of other functions that won't
do this
when I used +10 farc inside
matías farc I can pass an
identification
automatically the land will look for the
name or names and it will say that this
is the identification of each one of
these entries
so I can pass  ar the name of the
file as the identification and I tell
it to put the filename column
so when I run this I notice
that now I already have a new column a
new variable that has the value
of the file
and when I did it it had to be this
before  to learn your style and see if this would
n't have closed two lines I don't know if it
's for you it's different but this is
this is incredibly and it's powerful the
fs function with the
land function is solving so many problems that
we can see there that and  very easily and
we can read it easily
the next thing we want to do
is that as human beings our
brain automatically knows how to read
that's the third grade and I'm looking at you
fifth grade because
we can automatically discard these two parts and
just focus on the center  but
obviously when we do the data analysis we do
n't want all that information
we just want the degree
for that we can use the function
this wall that we used in our
our first exercise in the first
webinar what we do with servet is
that it takes the file and automatically
this wall reads them to any character
or any letter that is more
punctuated since everything is
com.  ar is going to consider it as a
separation so if I pass
this file and that the and
different columns separate them in this case 1 2 3 and
4 then what I expect is that it gives me
1 2 3 and 4 when I run it
is  exactly what I expected is
fourth grade csd data each in its
own
its own column and as you can
see I have the names in Spanish so
the name does not matter the only one the only thing
that matters is that I pass one
formation to
the other  thing that this bread has is to say
that it starts from the left to the right
and if I leave it like that it didn't name things to the
right I don't just don't care about them
so if I simply say that I
care about 1 and 2
and with a face again notice that  three  s and
four did not give me an error in the first place,
which is the most important thing,
simply from a warning problem,
but if it brings me the number two, which
is the value that I need
and one,
what usually varies after this
is to do something like a  select
select and minus one to only
keep 2 which would be ok but it
is electric it
would be fine we have four here and you already
renamed it whatever but there is a track
other trick than this but you have to see
if you pass an n
in the place where  there is the variable
that you do not want automatically it is
lost it is going to discard it
so instead of passing it 1 and 2 here
I pass it degree I have left degree to
return from doing these two steps of 1
here and then remove it simply
happened to it and  There is only one degree left, that is,
I am going with three lines,
I went from
having to fetch all the files, read them,
add the name of the file and
then get the name of the degree,
I can do this very easily,
I need
can instead of em  start with files
I can say that it starts with the one that is the
fs function that does the reading of the
files and that I separated the degree everything
is one step there are three very
small functions that all of us who have
been learning do it step by step here it
does it  quickly we finished and because I
'm starting with I'll say if tomorrow
I add another file here or I don't
have to change any single code it
just runs again in the
information the code sorry and strafe
new information
we can know how powerful the
combination is  del talde bears when you
add one thing it's like a dog
the truth is what I want to do is
clean the data because as if
we remember and if we go to the
first webinar these are not
clean data because here there are two
observations it's not just one for what
be clean data each line has to
be an observation all we want to
do is have english and math
be on their own line this is the one i
copied ex  exactly how is it in the
first in the first exercise of the
webinar the first webinar to the same
steps
so clean data so as not to talk
much about this but this one for another time if
we talk about this bread and then khadr is used
to make a line for each  one
but more information is in this
webinar and here I have the link and
we are also going to deal with other links as you can
find this webinar and here
we already have here some clean data
loose bunk
one of the lines is a grade a score
usually what  what would we do if we want to
make groups with this with these
data we use groups if we want the
average for each subject for each
person or enrollment of the
students I simply make a profile and
then add izar to
each score I make the min of the points
I already have the  average
this would be this is what we use i
say 80% of the time but what happens
when we need to do something more
complex with each of these groups
what if you want  we would run maybe
a model for each of these groups
we can't run here
no it doesn't work that way
so what is the way we can do this
problem since we go from
vector functions to functions with or with pur and
how can we do these  cycles and now
how we can do this type of groups
operations by groups returning to the
presentation
we are going to talk about data groups with
player money it is obviously where
we are going to do the
data transformations which is exactly what this is
we already have the clean data  that is, we
went from reading about cleaning and now we are going
to transform the transformations we
do with beach and beach has
a function that is very important but
before seeing this function I want to talk
about the types of something very interesting that
daily provides  bears this type of
tables or super tables that are called
old,
the reason is that they are not strip framestore
tables, it is that tivo has them among
several  things that they do, one of the most
important is that they allow you to
have groups of
other tables as variables within
tables, that is, you can have tables
within tables, as you can see here
, how this example tries to do, has a table
within the table, I have  another table and
when you look at it with a new run you
want to see how this table is printed it
will be because within the data it
says I am going to you
but within this data is that there is
a table
this is important to know because as I
was saying to you  player has a
function called group nest group
nest automatically changes the places
but it is simply a group
and it is going to create a group and the rest of the
information is going to be filtered
inside a table inside the
main table in this case  we have two
people we have a juan one and sofia two
and we have two tickets for each one
so instead of grouping them as a
group there is ago
when I do groupme it's name and
surname it will believe  ar two tables that are
going to have these each one is going to have
these two values and these two values are w
pen this table here from juan one is
going to say January days he was going to say Februar
10 and when he speaks to bradl he challenges
he sil February 20  and January 5
the other thing we have to
do
since once they are inside each
one is three of their table and I can now
run a more complex operation
using map in you take you take it will
create the new variable
and more it will  run
the function inside this type
and it will give me the result in another
column but since tivo is quite
flexible the column will be an
lm object instead of being some data something like that
then the combination now everything
is coming together we are starting
with kurt and now we are undeclared and
in the previous Fridays we have talked
about the player since we all see
how they fit there as well and we can
fit it to do this type of
more complex operations as I was
talking about in the beginning  start now let's see
how this works
using here
we go to the data groups
as promised
we go from clean data to group
nest remember that we did group by here
because we are going to be with just
and instead of giving me some humanization it
is simply giving me the rest  of
the data without individual tables what I
am going to do is I am going to record these
results in the groups variable
and to demonstrate that we can see the
data
I can ask me from the first to the
first line which would be this here and I am going
to use
the pull command  so that it gives me the data
of the cover column, you
can see that elena jiménez is there
and I have a problem with printing,
but the name of elena
jiménez can be there and I can see here that although I
cannot read the eme jiménez here it says
that these data  are inside the a of
this type
before going to the next step which would be
because we already have all these in their
own tivo now I want to be able to
run a model for each one but
before doing e  I want to introduce another
idea, remember that we can do
this type of mapping like
this, that is, it will stretch water and ahmed to
capitalize everything, obviously this is a
vector function, we can do it in
another way, but to make it easier,
certainly we are going to here the  another
thing in another way that I can do this
is by using this symbol
where we see in
and when we pass this
we have to pass x is the name of the
file,
that is, if I pass without stowage it acts
but it is simply passing the point x
becomes  that this variable if
something like names dot x gives me the names
it would not be with soul
then if I do this arthur for
exactly the same results as
with this one
the next thing I want to do is that it
is that we use this this function that
is why this  we are going to agree on a
function but if I want to run more than
one function or something a little more complex
then I have to use this type of
operation like this with the with the ñ and with the
dot x in this case I want to do two
functions I want it to remove data
and then it will be stewart whopper
and the base
yes so I can do it these two
ways but we have to do it this
way when we do a more complex operation it
's a bit
more newer we have to learn but
believe me it's worth practicing
when one can do this
easily it's powerful cam and this is what I
use every day when I do a
trade and only ends up something like that
with this type of trade
what are we going  let's see here now that
we already have groups and that each group is a
crop we are going to do more
the data is that later we are going to say that
a linear regression model is run
but since
the value that is going to pass is not the first one
but it is  really the last one because
we are being the ñ and the point that
is at the end as data equal to the point x
when I run here it
already gives me my model and everything is inside
the type
and then I can do another co  sa what
would be to use this model to make a
prediction
and we get to month 6 in this data
so I'm going to pass a in the 7 to
make a prediction and wes the same thing if you
notice it's the same thing instead of
using
the column  data I am going to use the [ __ ] column
to make the prediction I am going to run it for you I
already have the prediction here
as this note is inside a list it
is one it is a result inside a
list that is double or numeric
I would like not to see this because  'it is only to
say that it is a number that I would like to see
the number
so since we know that maps will always
give me a
list remember which one to use
so that it gives me a number if we are
here
the presentation
a vector  numeric you can use marta
bolt it's the same as here
and you used martagón it
already automatically gives me a version that
is the number since it doesn't give me the list it
's more convenient if I don't have to
go from here a minute ago something
like that to convert  the  studio double
just used mcdowell
so we used another mac family
and as we put this together little by little sometimes it's
a bit hard to see how easy it is to
do all these operations so
I put them here we're going to give the clean
agrup nest and then the 2006
or  either we went
with three actions quickly we made
a model for each of the
students for 48 students since we
made 48 models and 48 predictions without
end
ok
let's go a little further
remember that we talked that we are going to
learn about track 2
and transportation and let's go  here and
the values of columns are converted to lines, which is what
hat means if I
o here and run this
peration, it will give three colum
s because I am making a group and t
en simply give me the human
zations if I use map on it to
this of this table
of what I am doing here through
the pipe is that instead of giving me an
entry for each line it is giving me an
entry for each column and that is  what
happens with we combine marc with tables more
automatically if I don't pass it as I
did here in new tape
but I'm passing it completely the
table to the map it will think that each
one of the entries is one of the
columns
we will solve this with  transports if you
use 32
and I show all the students here
note that each student becomes a
number this is an entry degrees
is alberto ramírez entry 3 is rodrigo
hernández entry 4 and so each entry
becomes one to one of the lines
then yes  you have to cut batman
for the column and transports for the line
and that is very common because we usually
need to do this type of
operations for each line and if the line
is not something else it is added as it would be
that fields we have to use more nest
then use transport  It's about to
arrive, it's going to give you the list as you
don't need to use it because this is
important because the last thing I
want to teach you today is
that after I already  we have the
students I can now pass another function
kills since students remember that
it is now that it has an entry for
each student I can now pass a
bolt map and it will give me the
enrollment number because each entry is a
student is a line
We can use this because sometimes
we want to make automatic reports in
the previous webinar, we did something very
similar to using a report to be
able to automate it and generate several
reports based on enrollment, but
what happens if what we want to do is
what
can happen?  more information than just the
license plate last time we only made
one point of information in this we
need more and that is why
transportation is always there it
is so important because the
information is already ready for it you
can use more against
a table that was passed  by transports
and when you do this what you are going to do
here is that you are going to have my
this document is armed that has
parameters and  which has the parameter is
matriculation and I am passing here matriculation parameter
that I am going to do the name of the file
here
and that it goes to this force called
cards when I run this
and go to the cards folder I can see
here how each repetition to each  layer the
report is being generated
automatically it
says that these reports are going to be
generated by code so they will not
have errors that there is someone among
the wrong information
I can while I am working I can
see here
the student card that has a
chip with the name of  the student
to open another here two bands
here I have rodrigo since I create each
of the reports just by running this
code we can also do the same
thanks to a new integration we
have with power point you can do the
same compare point sim and here we have
the same  the same idea that we can
generate each file to the park west
and
pass it the same information as if I go
here to present it  ntation
cards
here is the auto spark presentation which
is
the main point and the same idea since
we can pass the parameter with
license plate we make a small but
something interesting here since he used
a woman here to make a new slide
and equipment to put  put your comment
here and what is the result of this is
that when I run this
this code that is the same thing the
only thing I am doing is passing it to
a normal one so different that it is
prepared to be done by point and I am going to the
presentations it
is creating  I'm going to open
a presentation here
until they have
Alberto's results and here I have
the slide and the teacher to put his
comment
better
then that is something very common also
that this is usually the reason
why they ask us to do sporting
because  they want to put comments
then and already inside the arming so that
it generates it only puts a
new slide there so that they put their
comment and it has gone and  each one of the
reports generates them automatically
very well so this is the one I wanted to
share today other speeches available resources such
as the fastest shorts
and chips or the reference sheet
we have here I have the link to thanks to
carlos ortega we also have the guide
quick why is that what we have
been talking about today so I am
quite happy that there is this this
work that you can download
the quick guide and use nothing
we also have the resources in Spanish
especially I am going to binner them you will
notice that we have if you remember  by
víctor sessa spanish study
if you put a little mark it is in this link
here is where we are going to start adding
all the resources in spanish
obviously we have two now which are the
videos
and also all the materials that
we use during these webinars gestures
then like me  I made quite a few
references to those previous webinars
and if you haven't seen them yet you can
come here and in easy to learn  and remember to
be arts
lóriz west dotcom spanish here you just
have to come back also for when
we post today's video so you
can see it again or share it and
I also put here some resources in
English as we said at the beginning all
these materials are going to be  available
in that link where the resource is in
Spanish and there will be a link there to be
able to go and bring all the resources
so thank you very much for your attention
to the extra
I am very excited that this has been
our third webinar and today we are going to
do  more gestures then before we
finish I think we have a couple
of minutes to answer a couple of
questions
we have two questions here I think
yes then we have a question to
return a tegra frame should I use cfr if
the answer is there are 3
three starmax functions of  efe that
returns that is equal to map of fr
and it is also wrong of efe this one that is
by column
for example it is possible to do if you are
this
although desp  After a group you can
use groups if you need but the idea
is that today we wanted to demonstrate
groupon is that it is one of the most recent functions
of the player and group nest
will not only be able to do as we
demonstrated here was the information
not only  it is going to be a model it can
also be the predictions and really
expand what you can put inside a
type to the other question we have here
the series what would the code be if you made a
group I want to add a column for
example put the line number by
each his group in this group
and I think what he means is this
so I guess we're going groups
here I'm going to know what each presenter
knows is the number one rule of not
to do no I don't have to do a something
live and try it for  first time live
but we are going to do it since we don't have
little time here you are going to do a quickie
here the whole idea is what happens if I
want to add a column to the
table
then since  we have data let's
do data that's how I would do it I'm not
sure if it would be if it is
and I want to add it to the row
of c's
min
30 again
brow name
i
groupme
country I think I put a tasting drink on it
[Music]
kate it
would be something like that but no  not the three if they
don't come right now it can't be the new is
inside the map but obviously no I
'm not I don't have all the steps
this goes on like this while it finds out that
another
one of the remaining programs I've
had is to load
large databases  you can slow down the
process a lot to load and several operate several
databases that
port options and other database reading methods also work
because usually what we want to do
with databases is not to load all
the databases
yes not to
use a  other types
of methods how to use we saw a
functions of haiti player against the
database so the preparation of data
is not within r but it is to pass it
within the database  think
groupings filters selections all
all these kinds of operations the
database can do it so
one better consider this type of method to
this the place on the internet should dot
rewrite dotcom is the place on the internet
where we are eating all this
our ideas will support  overview and this
is where we talk about this type of method,
that is, the best the best thing to
do to import data from the
database is not to import hc databases
try to avoid that for the
generated models the m you can define the  level
of confidence that you want if you can, you
simply have to add nothing that
would be in the prediction to when you use
the prediction here
the projectile where he adds it
by pressure
I have a list of frame tasks of
different dimensions I want to create a
solo in the prime we have  the rows and
columns with n when
initial and higher is not applied this has been with
creative methods if it can be done this
can be done at  I will say straits with various
dimensions that are different and fill
in it
with this you can use aerate and
depending on how you are
putting them together to put on you use that khadr
in aid of each of these
that helps each of these functions
deteriorates
you can see  what does the ceo say to
drink a non-expert cold drink,
for example, spread has action if you
want to fill it with something specific you
can change this filter value but
there are others that give other functions I would
try
to cover the two points that I can
answer today and we have reached the
time  and I want to thank you again for
your attention to your questions and I hope
that you are very grateful for your satisfaction
and that it is something that is something new that you can
use in your daily tasks so we are
going to stop at the presentation and
thank you again for having a  happy
day
and
[Music]